cet institut de beauté qui a la
particularité de proposer également un
hammam a rouvert ses portes le 12 mai
après deux mois de fermeture de moi
blanc en termes de chiffre d'affaires
mais pas concernant le travail après
avoir réglé l'aspect administratif et
les nombreuses procédures pour les aides
des reports de charges
le couple de gérants à rénover ses
locaux cette période 2 avril mais il une
des plus importantes de l'année pour
leur activité c'est la préparation des
mariages et les enterrements de vie de
jeune fille sont des moments importants
pour nous puisqu'on a des groupes de dix
à quinze personnes qui venaient en même
temps jusqu'à aujourd'hui
actuellement l'entreprise n'effectue que
20% de son chiffre d'affaires habituel
alors pour rassurer les clients une
charte est mise en place
en suivant les recommandations du
ministère du travail afficher dans
l'institut est envoyé par mail à la
clientèle fidèle à l'esprit que ce qu'on
leur demande de faire et on explique sur
le point sur lequel on s'engage ce qu'on
leur demande de faire au préalable avant
de venir cette prendre des rendez-vous
le port du masque est aussi obligatoire
excepté dans le hammam où seule une
personne par salle est acceptée de son
côté l'équipe porte elle aussi un masque
et une visière en plus pour les soins
les cabinets salles sont désinfectés
entre chaque client l'eau et les
magazines à disposition sont retirés et
le thé ne peut plus être offertes ou on
est positif et on avance on a fait tout
ce qu'il faut pour remettre à eau propre
ici et tout est quasiment neuf le
plafond été refaite
tout a été refait tout c'est bien
partout mais maintenant il faut que lyon
revienne
les gérants espèrent pouvoir faire
revenir leurs salariés aujourd'hui en
chômage partiel petit à petit avec la
reprise d'activité partenaire des boks
cadeau il se montre patient et attendre
que ses clients des tendeurs de boxe
prennent rendez vous pour venir se
détendre